tf1 13 heures avec jean claude bourret
pluie neige et froid c'est le menu
métérologiques de votre week-end et cela
à quatre jours de l'été renault
négociations syndicats-direction à flins
depuis ce matin 11 heures demain auteuil
grand steeple-chase de paris 6500 mètres
18 partants 28 obstacles et un tiercé
paris est aujourd'hui la capitale des
carnavals une grande cavalcade de
l'hôtel de ville à la concorde de 15
heures à 17 heures madame mademoiselle
monsieur bonjour il y avait trois degrés
ce matin à clermont ferrand
7° à perpignan 8 degrés à toulouse 10
degrés à paris et 12 à cannes il neige
juste au dessus de chamonix aux environs
de 12 100 m bref la france grelotte
et pourtant dans quatre jours c'est
l'été alors avec monsieur météo avec guy
la rivière les espoirs de ce week end
fruits pour les températures ce matin je
pense pas qu'il s'agisse de records
puisque au moins deux ans on a déjà noté
un degré seulement à nevers enfin ceci
étant c'est vrai qu'on est au niveau des
plus basses températures au moins pour
celles de l'après midi par exemple hier
pour les températures d'après midi on a
battu des records aussi bien à alençon
que dans tout le sud ouest et à
montélimar avec des températures de
l'ordre selon les endroits de 13 à 17
degrés et tout ce mauvais temps et bien
est aujourd'hui à ce grand tourbillon
qui recouvre toute la france et les
pluies après être passé sur le sud ouest
sont partis sur la provence ont remonté
vers la bourgogne les alpes puis
reviennent maintenant sur le nord de la
france et probablement cet après midi
sur la région parisienne
c'est donc le plus mauvais temps qu'on
peut avoir en ce moment une amélioration
espérer quand même pour dimanche soir ou
lundi au moins sur la moitié nord de la
france et puis vous voyez d'autres
pluies pour le début de la semaine
probable disons que pour demain et bien
sûr une grande partie de la france au
sud de la loire et sur toutes les
régions de l'est et la méditerranée on
va avoir un temps à averses et orages
avec bien sûr par endroits quand même
des éclaircies et toujours des chutes de
au dessus de 13 cents ou quinze 100 m
alors là y'a un petit progrès je sais
pas si vous saisirez la nuance mais il
ya un mois il neigeait à 900 mètres donc
on va bien quand même vers l'été enfin
disons que c'est bien progressé et puis
sur le nord de la france de la bretagne
et de la normandie à la belgique le
matin temps très couvert peut être avec
quelques pluies encore par endroits mais
l'après midi nous devrions avoir sur ces
régions tout de même déjà des éclaircies
qui seront plus belle par conséquent
dans la journée de lundi des
températures un petit peu en hausse sur
l'ensemble de la france mais qui reste
toujours en dessous de ce qu'on peut
attendre au mois de juin disons 18 quand
même sur le nord et dans le sud ouest et
20 à 22 degrés près de la méditerranée a
quand même à paris en tout cas c'est la
chaleur humaine qui va compenser le côté
frisk et de la météo le carnaval des
carnavals va défiler dans les rues et
sur la scène
l'année dernière cette manifestation
organisée par europe 1 avait connu un
très grand succès cette année europe 1
et l'hôtel de ville renouvelle
l'expérience grâce à une quinzaine de
délégations venues de tous les pays du
monde
enfin de beaucoup de pays en tout cas ce
soir à 22 heures défilé de chars navale
sur la scène et parmi eux le grand
bateau des tiffin dessiné par catherine
chalier pour l'instant tous les groupes
folkloriques sont devant l'hôtel de
ville de paris en direct de l'hôtel de
ville nous retrouvons maurice allais
olivan oui voici
c'est avant tout des fier aux assistés
en fin de journal vous avez là
actuellement à l'image
l'école de samba de bahia flore cela
même si maintenant depuis trois années
consécutives remporte le concours du
carnaval de rio
c'est sans doute la troupe la plus
prestigieuse de ce carnaval
bien sûr ce ne sont là que quelques-unes
des 14 troupes qui composent ce carnaval
des carnavals 78 14 groupes réunissant
devant l'hôtel de ville plus de 800
personnes en fin de journal jacques
chirac et son épouse viendront nous
rejoindre sur le podium installé devant
la mairie de paris
ensemble nous assisterons à la totalité
de ce défilé qui devrait durer environ
une bonne dizaine de minutes
alors si vous le voulez bien jean claude
bouron se retrouve dans une vingtaine de
minutes rencontre direction-syndicats à
flins le juge des référés du tribunal de
versailles a fait injonction à la
direction de renault d'ouvrir les
négociations dans les 48 heures et il a
demandé aux grévistes parallèlement de
ne pas entraver la liberté du travail
les négociations ont repris depuis un
peu plus de deux heures entre syndicats
et direction de renault à flins
françois go ou direction et syndicats
négocient pour tenter de mettre fin au
conflit rhône au conflit de l'usiné de
flins on négocie exactement dans ce
bâtiment derrière moi et là négociations
risquent de durer toute la journée et
même peut-être toute la journée de
demain pour la première fois en france
un tribunal celui de versailles en juin
un employeur de négocier et en même
temps il a enjoint aux grévistes
d'évacuer l'atelier des grandes presse
l'atelier occupé l'atelier de la grève
bouchons dans les 48 heures alors sur
quoi négocié ton et bien je vous
rappelle la revendication essentielle
des grévistes et des syndicats c'est la
promotion professionnelle
ils sont au s les grévistes ils volent
devenir p 1
comme promis par la direction ce qui
d'ailleurs correspondrait à une
augmentation d'environ 82 francs par
mois la direction de la régie pour sa
part a proposé une amélioration
accélérée des conditions de travail de
l'enrichissement des tâches comme on dit
ainsi qu'une légère augmentation de
salaire par conséquent les bases de la
négociation ce matin l'est
et ateliers des grandes presse sont
toujours occupés mais si la négociation
évolue favorablement et bien les
grévistes pourraient les évacués avant
l'échéance fixée par le tribunal de
versailles c'est à dire avant demain 18
heures autour de la table de négociation
le climat reste tendu et l'on saura ce
soir si un compromis est possible dans
les arsenaux les fédérations cgt cfdt fo
et cftc ont appelé l'ensemble des
personnels à la généralisation de la
grève les syndicats ont décidé d'autre
part d'écrire une lettre commune au
ministre de la défense nationale pour
l'ouverture de négociations sur
l'ensemble des problèmes chez moulinex
200 des 650 employés de l'usiné moulinex
de fresnay-sur-sarthe occupent leur
entreprise depuis hier midi la direction
a décidé le lock out des ouvriers non
grévistes afin d'éviter d'éventuels
incidents
m denise thouanel tournoi a été libéré
hier soir à 20h15 de la prison de fleury
mérogis où elle était incarcérée depuis
quatre jours l'avocate était inculpé de
sortie irrégulière de correspondance
d'un établissement pénitentiaire et à sa
sortie de prison cet avocat t'as fait
une très courte déclaration dans
laquelle elle a souligné que ces
interrogatoires s'était déroulée de la
façon la plus courtoise mais simplement
vous rappeler que j'appartiens à un
avocat du barreau de paris que la parole
pour l'instant revienne à mon bâtonnier
que manifestement je risque de
saturation d'autres choses voilà c'est
on joue mieux quand même remercier par
votre intermédiaire mais défense m
chaque dreyfus c'est mon ami rémy suède
qui par la particulière compétences
que cette colle aux instructions et
leurs interrogatoires se fasse dans un
climat à la place un objectif et ce avec
une particulière sévérité peut également
remercier malgré tout monsieur le juge
gagnon d'avoir fait proche parfois d'une
certaine délicatesse pendant les
entretenant dans les interrogatoires et
je veux surtout remercier monsieur le
bâtonnier
une grande partie des confrères et
beaucoup d'amis qui ont continué à
accorder leur confiance et qui m'ont
témoigné plusieurs fois de tuer mon
travail j'ai plusieurs fois des
témoignages consignés
ils ont grand besoin de liberté chez les
avocats comme vous je suis très et suis
très content et je suis très émue pour
moi et je suis très contente en fait de
penser c'est un mouvement de solidarité
parce que à travers cette histoire aussi
mensongère très malencontreuse toute la
profession a subi vague et je suis
contente de voir que la profession peut
également se ressouder dans un cas comme
ceux qui au congrès de l'union syndicale
des magistrats a strasbourg le garde des
sceaux monsieur peyrefitte a répondu aux
inquiétudes manifestées par monsieur
andré braunschweig sur l'indépendance
des magistrats
l'indépendance est un état d'esprit et
une volonté a expliqué le garde des
sceaux
le juge doit être indépendant 200 milieu
de ces préjugés de sa classe et de
lui-même a conclu monsieur alain
peyrefitte le système d'indemnisation du
chômage et plein de trous qui permettent
la fraude c'est ce que monsieur yvon
chotard vice président du patronat
français a déclaré hier soir à grenoble
il faut sauvegarder et faire fructifier
l'entente majoritaire car c'est elle qui
permet au gouvernement d'exercer
l'action nécessaire au service de la
france
ainsi s'est exprimé monsieur raymond
barre hier soir à bron devant le conseil
national du centre national des
indépendants et paysans
le comité directeur du mouvement des
radicaux de gauche va élire aujourd'hui
ses dirigeants nationaux autour de
michel crépeau sera présenté une équipe
unie avec notamment quatre vice
présidents mais les radicaux de gauche
ont également étudié l'organisation de
leur parti l'europe et le financement
des partis politiques
un sujet d'actualité puisqu'il a été
évoquée par le président valéry giscard
d'estaing lors de sa récente réunion de
presse le président de la république en
effet souhaité que le gouvernement
élabore un projet de loi sur le
financement des partis politiques
patrick de carolis
si l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur
peut-il faire la politique meeting
location de salles campagne d'affichage
tracts bref tout ce qui est propagande
coûte cher et ce n'est pas avec la seule
contribution des adhérents que les
états-majors peuvent-ils faire face
alors d'où vient l'argent
la réponse ne manquent pas pour certains
du patronat des fonds spéciaux du
gouvernement pour d'autres des banques
de quelques mécènes particulièrement
riche
ou pourquoi pas de l'étranger en fait
mystère
les partis politiques reste muet sur la
trésorerie et le caractère clandestin de
leurs financements arrivent à créer il
faut bien le dire un climat parfois
malsain moraliser tout cela c'est le
voeu de l'ensemble de la classe
politique et le président de la
république dès sa première réunion de
presse en juillet ce sont 14 en avait
exprimé le souhait l'opposition dans son
programme commun prévoyait la
publication du budget de chaque partie
la majorité quant à elle par
l'intermédiaire de guy cabanel député
udf déposé en 76 une proposition de loi
relative aux ressources des partis
politiques
c'est dans ce sens également que le
mouvement des radicaux de gauche a
décidé ce week-end d'adopter lui aussi
une proposition de loi
la proposition doit des radicaux de
gauche comporte quatre réformes
la première réforme c'est de plafonner
les dépenses électorales pour empêcher
les campagnes ruineuse tapageuse qui
dégrade la politique en spectacle et qui
favorise les candidats et les partis
fortune
la seconde réforme c'est de faire que
l'état contribue réellement au
financement de la vie publique c'est un
peu ce qui existe en allemagne fédérale
et le même système transposer en france
reviendrait à 5 francs par électeur
c'est à dire environ 2 litre le super ce
n'est pas une dépense impossible à
assumer la troisième réforme ce serait
de réglementer et de démocratiser le
financement privé les partis politiques
en autorisant par exemple les
contribuables à déduire de leur revenu
imposable le versement qu'ils auraient
effectué auprès d'un parti politique et
la quatrième mesure c'est la publicité
des comptes les partis politiques les
lecteurs de pouvoir voter en
connaissance de cause en sachant qu'ils
dépensent quoi qui finance qui rien
n'est pire au fond que la loi du silence
rien n'est pire que le liaison secrète
quelles que soient les propositions de
loi il est demandé à l'état d'intervenir
alors reste à savoir à présent sur quels
critères seront calculées les
subventions allouées aux partis
politiques faut-il tenir compte de la
force électoral c'est-à-dire des
suffrages recueillis ou faut-il
s'appuyer sur la force parlement
c'est à dire sur le nombre de sièges
obtenus dans la proposition de loi que
j'avais présenté dès 1976 et j'avais
utilisé d'ailleurs les deux critères les
deux paramètres et d'une part il
existait une subvention de base au
nombre de voix obtenu par une formation
politique au premier tour des élections
législatives et d'autre part
j'envisageais une subvention
complémentaire au nombre d'élus suivants
sont complémentaires qui nous
représentait en gros que 30% de la
première car les élus du deuxième tour
sont souvent le fait de coalition et on
distingue mal à ce moment là l'étiquette
politique elle n'est pas déterminante
une seule étiquette politique n'est pas
déterminante dans l'élection du deuxième
tour en fait qu'il s'agisse de limiter
les dépenses sauvage de nos partis ou
d'augmenter leurs ressources afin qu'ils
puissent remplir leur mission
il semblerait bien qu'on ne puisse
libérer la politique de l'argent qu'en
donnant de l'argent à la politique
95% des eaux de mer sur les plages des
côtes du nord sont de bonnes ou de très
bonne qualité c'est le résultat des
contrôles bactériologiques réalisé par
la préfecture de saint-brieuc
il y a eu 82 points d'analysé des eaux
de mer sur 350 kilomètres de rivages du
département mais la baignade a tout de
même été interdite sur quatre sites
trois mois après la catastrophe de
l'amoco cadiz le préfet et les
responsables du tourisme des côtes du
nord ont dressé un bilan des opérations
de nettoyage sur les 120 km de côtes
touchées par le mazout dans les côtes
d'une heure quatre secteurs n'ont pu
être remis en état
il s'agit de la côte rocheuse alokpo de
la rivière les guerres démarrer il de
trébeurden et pleumeur-bodou ainsi que
d'une partie des îles et zone de galets
de ploucs et plougrescant mais partout
ailleurs les plages sont propres à 90 ou
100 pour cent quarante trois plages ont
été entièrement nettoyée quinze
passagers d'un autocar ont été blessées
dans une collision entre leur véhicule
et un poids lourd hier soir près de
saintes en charente-maritime
l'accident a provoqué également un
sérieux embouteillage
journée triomphale pour le président
jimmy carter à panama le président
américain est venu signer les traités
qui donneront le canal de panama au
panaméen les traités entreront en
vigueur dès que le sénat américain ont
approuvé les décrets d'application c'est
à dire au plus tard le 1er octobre 79
le président jimmy carter était
manifestement ravi de l'accueil
triomphal qu'il a reçus de la population
de panama autre motif de satisfaction
pour le président américain dans l'ain
dont la cote reste à ses bases dans
l'opinion publique américaine
la remarquable convergence des
politiques étrangères américaines et
chinoises
le processus de normalisation des
relations pékin washington s'accélère
conformément à ce que souhaite le
président carter de washington dominique
bromberger depuis le retour de monsieur
bré jeans qui à washington
voici trois semaines environ les signes
de rapprochement sino américains n'ont
cessé de se multiplier
tout d'abord on a appris que les états
unis avaient l'intention de retirer
d'ici le 1er octobre près de 50% de
leurs conseillers militaires en poste à
formose or précisément le retrait de
tout le personnel militaire américain de
sept-îles est l'une des conditions mises
en avant par le gouvernement de la chine
populaire pour une normalisation des
relations entre les deux pays
d'où une série de rumeurs qui ne cessent
de circuler à washington malgré les
démentis officiels sur la reprise des
relations diplomatiques entre pékin et
washington
second signe la première escale de
monsieur wang hu a le ministre chinois
des affaires étrangères à son retour des
états unis a été pour kinshasa
là il a rencontré le général mobutu il
l'a félicitée d'avoir repoussé et
l'agression étrangère et lui a promis
une certaine forme d'assistance
enfin les états unis viennent d'annoncer
qu'ils autoriseraient la livraison à la
chine populaire d'un matériel de
reconnaissance aérienne par infrarouge
ultra perfectionné qui en principe des
applications civiles telles que la
recherche de
na pétrolifères mais qui peut également
avoir des applications militaires telles
que la localisation de base ou de
troupes sur terre ou de sous marins sous
mer or précisément l'exportation de ce
matériel à cause des implications
militaires en question avait été refusée
à l'union soviétique
tout se passe en somme comme si une
alliance de fait une alliance qui n'ose
pas dire son nom était en train de se
dessiner entre washington et pékin
tf1 washington en italie les élections
présidentielles auront lieu le 29 juin
prochain les mille dix parlementaires
des deux chambres se réuniront en séance
conjointe pour élire un nouveau
président de la république italienne
après la démission de monsieur giovanni
les hommes en argentine sept prisonniers
politiques ont été libérés la semaine
dernière ses sept prisonniers ont été
autorisés pour la plupart à quitter le
pays ethiopie après la prise de pouvoir
par les militaires progressistes les
difficultés demeurent en ethiopie un
reportage de notre envoyé spécial
régis faucon l'ethiopie d'aujourd'hui un
double visage celui de la révolution et
celui de la répression
la révolution c'est la mobilisation
permanente les grandes manifestations de
masse les défilés interminables les
discours fleuves des dirigeants
militaires les slogans les banderoles et
cetera
ici dans le stock d'addis abeba c'est la
jeunesse qui défilent garçons et filles
sont embrigadés les fusils sont en bois
mais on ne cache pas à ces jeunes qu'ils
doivent se préparer pour le grand combat
des milliers d'entre eux iront assister
le mois prochain 11e festival de la
jeunesse mondiale à cuba et certains y
resteront pour suivre des cours
d'entraînement à la lutte
révolutionnaire l'autre côté c'est la
répression c'est celle qui visent tous
ceux qui pensent autrement ou simplement
les tièdes qualifié de contre
révolutionnaires ils sont pourchassés
sans pitié c'est le cycle des règlements
de compte des assassinats et des
exécutions sommaires les témoignages ne
manquent pas tel celui de sept étudiants
réfugiés à djibouti ont mis à bas
en ce qui me concerne j'étais étudiant à
l'université
toutes les nuits venez dans les dortoirs
à la recherche des suspects fat des
suspects et briand est bon en fait tout
le monde est suspect là bas ils ont tué
mes hommes
vous l'avez vue qui fait et english
discount a révolutionné la révolution en
anglais on les appelle les gardes
révolutionnaires ils ont été entraînés
par les cubains qui les ont tués
torturés même des enfants de 5 ans qui
tous les jours des jeunes tous le matins
vous allez dans les rues d'addis abeba
dit vous pouvez voir des dizaines de
morts
surtout les jeunes surtout des jeunes si
le corps des sapeurs pompiers de paris
et composé de militaires communs tous
l'ont d'ailleurs l'immense majorité des
pompiers de france et civils ils sont à
la charge des villes ces pompiers des
villes et des départements
mais autrefois il y avait aussi dans
chaque village des pompiers volontaires
que l'on retrouve d'ailleurs encore dans
plusieurs départements
ces irréductibles ses hommes de bonne
volonté ne veulent pas voir leur village
à la seule merci d'un centre de secours
installé quelquefois 20 au kilomètre où
plus de l'endroit où est situé le
village
c'est le cas d'ailleurs d'un petit
village de seine et marne qui a toujours
eu ces pompiers volontaires et à une
époque où le bénévolat devient rare ces
sommes viennent de donner un bel exemple
de solidarité et de désintéressement
un reportage de jean françois robinet
c'est à peine si nous avons raccourci
cette séquence pour les besoins du monde
entre le premier semble steven et
l'arrivée sur les lieux
à un kilomètre de là il s'est écoulé
moins de trois minutes tout ici est
simulé est aussi vrai qu'à l'habitude
deux coups de sirène c'est un accident
de la route une asphyxie une chute de
cheval ou de roches est fréquente dans
la région ou encore un noyer nous sommes
à héricy au bord de la scène un village
de moins de 2000 habitants qui a
conservé son corps de pompiers
volontaires les hommes dévoués entraînés
qui en veulent ils viennent de le
prouver en fabricants eux-mêmes de
toutes pièces l'ambulance de secours de
leur mentir et qu'ils connaissent la
nature de l'accident
il appelle par radio le smur service
médical d'urgence un médecin une
infirmière arrive dans un véhicule léger
et avec l'équipement complémentaire
voilà
épouse on arrive avec le véhicule louis
qui est équipé de façon qu'à la radio
les les avertissements sonores et
lumineux et qui possèdent tous les
appareils très sophistiqués de
réanimation cardio vasculaires et
respiratoires
et si vous voulez la maison de ses deux
véhicules transforme l'ambulance des
pompiers en ambulance de réanimation
c'est cette ambiance qui a été conçu par
dans les heures de loisirs bien sûr
pendant un an nous avons ramassé les
métaux ferreux pour se faire un peu
d'argent
nous avons eu de nombreux dons bénévoles
comme du reste
et après une petite somme de la commune
un bon cadeau aux contribuables le but
d'une telle ambulance coûte environ 80
milles francs l'équipement est
maintenant complet et le corps des
récits espère bien être agréé
subventionné nous avons tous les frais
pour nous il ya là nous avons des
communes environnantes qui n'ont aucun
corps de secours et qui paye aussi la
même taxe que nous et ils n'ont aucuns
frais alors que souvent on la rend
service du fait quand il ya un accident
sur les autres tout ça ce qui est normal
d'ailleurs mais je trouve qu'on devrait
toucher une subvention par rapport aux
véhicules des hôpitaux aux autres
véhicules auxquels vous avez à faire est
ce qui est ce qu'il est aussi bien
techniquement c'est exactement le même
véhicule que les pompiers de paris nous
avons ces hommes qui comprend un chef de
corps l'adjudant chef un sous-chef
sergent-chef g4 caporaux et dit sa peur
quelles sont leurs métiers d'une
soixante général j'ai de la chance je
vais pas mal d'artisans entrepreneurs et
des ouvriers qui travaillent chez
l'entrepreneur sont kiwikaki avis et qui
permet d'avoir du monde dans le village
qu'est ce que vous faites vous même à
moi je suis artisan et vous moi je suis
maître de manège
telle profession entreprise paysagiste
dans le village dans le village n'a sont
dans le village chef cuisinier et vous
pouvez quitter s'il se passe quelque
chose vous entendu la sirène pendant les
repas vous pouvez partir tout de suite
oui bien sûr comment ça se passe avec le
patron mais le patron prendre forme à la
place près des hommes ça sympathique et
efficace
guy la rivière n'était pas très
optimiste tout à l'heure sur le temps de
ce week-end mais il faut espérer qu'avec
l'été le soleil reprendra sa place à
part entière
en tout cas côté maillot de bain tout
est prêt les des mini mini au maxi jean
claude narcy est allé à dinard en
bretagne pour assister à la mode 1978
des maillots de bain les couturiers et
des stylistes de prêt-à-porter qui sont
optimiste par nature ont rêvé un été
chaud c'est la raison pour laquelle
leurs maillots de bain sont cette année
plus réduit que jamais afin que chacun
puisse exposer au soleil le maximum
d'épiderme les maillots ont donc perdu
encore quelques centimètres carrés
les maillots deux pièces sont mini leurs
prix ne sont pas toujours quoi qu'on
trouve pour toutes les bourses des slips
de 80 francs à 500 francs malgré le
mauvais temps des dernières semaines les
fabricants ont tout de même bien vendu
ses clashs à la mayo de bas pour une
femme n'est pas toujours facile exemple
si une femme qui a une foi tiennent un
peu forte mais qui à part ça sera très
bien bonbons pas levé à partir du
principe que sa poitrine est trop forte
et qu'elle va cacher tout le reste c'est
parce qu'elle a une poitrine plus forte
alors qu'à la limite elle pourrait très
bien se mettre dans un deux pièces elle
serait très bien dedans et elle y pense
pas même pas
le maillot une pièce gagne du terrain
cela n'empêche pas d'être aussi sexy que
deux pièces car il est très échancré et
souvent retenu par des lacets il faut
savoir si vous avez quelque chose à
cacher les brûlures ou des opérations du
sein par exemple un certain nombre de
fabricants réalise des maillots sur
mesure pour l'homme de grande pendant
cette année le slip plastique très serré
mais surtout beaucoup de boxer short
s'inspirant du football ou de la boxe je
crois qu'en règle générale l'homme
n'essaye pas ils essayent beaucoup moins
que la femme jeudi à lome se connaît sa
taille
une fois qu'il la connaît il va choisir
dans une pile il prend celui qui a la
couleur qui venait et puis ils achètent
sylla je dire avant le jour où il c'est
sa taille ça se passe comme ça
jamais une femme de chambre un maillot
comme ça jamais pour l'après ben les
femmes porteront des robes mini des
robes en soleil les hommes des pantalons
en toile des t-shirts et puis des polos
qui reviennent en force
unisexe la grande mode cette année est
au bermuda au short long le plus souvent
ils sont blancs c'est le côté tennis de
la mode de l'été et les créateurs ont
été inspirées par le cinquantenaire de
roland garros
les sorties de bain sont peut-être moins
à la mode je veux parler des tenues
classiques
en revanche il y aura de grandes
serviette de bain qui se transforme
elles ont même des capuches le plus
souvent d'ailleurs ses tenues sont
assorties au maillot je pense que le
vêtements de plage proprement dit elle
qu'il est apparu il ya quelques années
encore donné de maillots etc
pour moi ça au niveau plans mode ça ne
n'est plus justifiée par contre ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il ya de plus en
plus d'autres vêtements qui sont portées
pour la plage pour avec les maillots là
ça devient de plus en plus
interchangeables dans les deux sens le
monokini seront encore porté cette année
pas partout il faut croire que les
femmes qui viennent ici à dinard sur la
côte d'émeraude sont plus prudents que
celle de la côte d'azur
enfin toutes ces tenues de plage seront
oubliés le soir pour des vêtements un
peu plus habillée la chemise remplacera
le t-shirt pour l'homme et puis la robe
à fleurs
la sortie de bain pour la fable il reste
à vous souhaiter que le soleil soit
toujours de la parcours au profiter à
fond de ses vacances 70 haltérophilie
nouveau record du monde du soviétique
rigueur il a amélioré son propre record
du monde de l'épaulé jeté avec 221 kg
500 autres record du monde celui du son
auteur battu également par un soviétique
youri diatchenko il a franchi 2 mètres
34 améliorant d'un centimètre son propre
record et puis un tiercé demain à
auteuil à auteuil en tire c'est
difficile alors andré théron les
pronostics eh bien oui demain c'est le
grand steeple-chase 6500 mètres c'est
très long 28 obstacle à franchir c'est
très difficile l'analyse de l'aco
jean-claude serait très difficile mais
il y à ces fameux mille derniers mètres
après avoir sauté il faut tenir en tête
de nos préférés le numéro 9 dans et lyon
qui trouve un poids très avantageux
cette fois le 13 nuque la d9 cheval type
d'auteuil
puis le 15 fondeur vainqueur du prix du
président la recette shing cours la
régularité faite cheval le 17 mon
filleul très bons éléments et pourquoi
pas le 4 bis qui n'a ensuite nous avons
des outsiders bien sûr avec le cese
forme le 10 pires mares vainqueur du
grand steeple en 76 le 5 le pompier
second l'an dernier le set mon petit
hall e 3 p'tits louis le 18 payet le 11
gringalet et le 2e chuck quelques
chevaux délaissé à très grosse cote au
nombre de quatre le 14e wrangler le 6 le
clos laurent le 12 aldin et le huit lots
nus clad hainaut sera l'un des favoris
de ce grand ce type
interview de son entraîneur françois
doumen
d'un beau cheval il a toujours été bon
on dirait qu'il a il a éclaté cette
saison
oui je crois que là maintenant j'allais
au sam
évidemment on dit ce qu'on dit que ça
mais il a beaucoup travaillé ces
derniers temps évidemment pour se
préparer sur scène et 500 m et là
vraiment récupéré à chaque fois d'une
façon formidable et je lai jeu les gays
et est très dur je crois très endurcis
comme on prépare un cheval point hors
site et plus moi je crois que il lui
faut progressivement de très loin de
plus en plus de travail une condition
physique exceptionnelle le grand saut
même pour un athlète bien sûr c'est
d'être d'abord musculairement condition
physique exceptionnelle et en souffle
pour pour tenir le coup si mes 500 m
c'est un bel athlète c'est un magnifique
athlète et un cheval très sérieux à
challes qui est qui pose aucun problème
de karaté de caractère d'une part et qui
dans gentil étant sérieux et courageux 3
qui réunit pas mal de mes qualités et il
est vraiment il est il est vraiment sur
le plan coalition physique mais je peux
rien reprocher aujourd'hui son jeu qaîda
meda confiant si je connais très bien
ils ont très confiance l'un dans l'autre
ils ont l'air de faire très bon ménage
alors il le connaît par coeur
françois ça représente quoi pour un
jeune entraîneur de remporter le grand
steeple-chase de paris c'est un peu
énervant
avant la courte à huy est bien vivant
c'est mon premier gros ce type comme les
animaux premier président bon sens
puisque je suis récemment installé
depuis un an et demi tout est bien
nouveau pour moi mais enfin oublier gré
insister à l'entraînement de mon père
pendant de nombreuses années et je vais
je reviendrai d'air france suffisamment
longtemps pour quand même connaître un
peu la musique me disant que le pedigree
de la famille domaines et
particulièrement fonctionnel c'est le
terme consacré pour savez je ne suis pas
avoir de conseil de la part de mon père
merci alors un très beau quand ce type
retour au carnaval des carnaval organisé
par europe 1 et l'hôtel de ville de
paris des dizaines de groupes
folkloriques danse devant la place de
l'hôtel de ville où nous rejoignons
maintenant maurice olivari ce que vous
voyez là
en fait c'est la répétition générale de
ce carnaval des carnavals oublie le
dirigeant peut trouver ce carnaval de
paris avait fait sa deuxième édition ce
qui a permis aux organisateurs de tirer
en quelque sorte les leçons de
l'expérience de quelques pays qui a
porté cette année l'éducation dès ce
matin l'ensemble de ses troupes
allemandes en paris pour aller en
quelque sorte ameuté la population et
dans quelques instants les 800
participants à ce défilé représentant 14
pays vont être reçus ici même à l'hôtel
de ville de paris par madame chirac
alors jacques chirac ou bien que la
mairie de paris ne soit pas directement
à l'origine de ce carnaval je crois que
vous êtes vous particulièrement vous
même attaché à cette notion de fête dans
la capitale oui je fais en général pour
redonner
de ville de paris la grande tradition
elle a eu beaucoup de fêtes dans le
temps et nous nous efforçons de le père
et le jeu
je suis très reconnaissant à l'europe du
verrou un d'avoir repris cette tradition
du carnaval qui existaient mais qui a
été abandonné depuis le plus haut depuis
plus de 40 ans pensez vous qu'il soit
possible de créer une tradition
carnavalesque à paris oui sans aucun
doute et la preuve c'est qu'elle
existait il s'agit donc pas de la cré et
de la reprendre et nous nous y
emploierons j'espère que l'europe veut
raconter duras dans ce domaine à nous
aider toujours dans le domaine de
l'animation parisienne est ce que vous
avez des projets particuliers oui nous
avons commencé vous l'avez vu avec le
relais sur le pont neuf
nous allons faire une manifestation
importante pour le retour des fêtes de
la saint jean samedi prochain sur cette
même place et pour le 14 juillet nous
allons faire en plus important que
l'année dernière nos fêtes de paris
village
nous préparons aussi de grands noël de
fête pour barry trouve ainsi michel mr
prenons maintenant à l'actualité avec ce
donc ce défilé du carnaval des carnavals
pour donner en quelque sorte un aperçu
un avant goût de ce que sera ce défilé
cet après midi et ce soir ce défi les
comprends je voulais 10 environ 800
représentant 800 personnes vous avez pu
voir en tête du défilé les représentants
français 130 accordéoniste venus de
paris de pontoise et de buzz ont
immédiatement suivi des personnages
grandeur nature de walt disney celui de
los angeles
viennent ensuite dans l'ordre les
représentantes de l'allemagne fédérale
avec une délégation du carnaval de
cologne
l'espagne qui a délégué également 60
représentants venus de tenerife le maroc
avec une soixantaine de danseurs venus
de marrakech
la pologne représentée par le groupe
bandeau ce cas vous allez découvrir
ensuite le togo avec 45 danseurs du
ballet national de l'eau mais le
portugal la suisse avec deux groupes
bien distinctes les représentants de
lucerne et de bâle pour la première fois
à paris les dragons à tête de lion venus
de hong kong
enfin quatre autres pays représentés en
fin de parcours
la colombie la grèce la hollande et bien
sûr honneur au plus prestigieux au plus
brillant des caravanes qui soit celui du
brésil avec la présence à paris de
l'école de samba beija flor celle là
même qui remporte depuis maintenant
trois années consécutives
le carnaval de rio le concours du
carnaval de rio
voilà pour les participants quand on
programme de la journée de rendez vous
de 15 heures à 17 heures le carnaval des
carnavals quittera la place de l'hôtel
de ville prend actuellement pour la
place de la concorde via la rue de
rivoli et bouquet final de 22 heures à
minuit avec le défilé des chars laval
sur la scène vous savez c'est l'une des
grandes originalités de ce carnaval de
paris
je défilais avait réuni sur les berges
de la seine l'année dernière plus de 1
million 200 mille personnes
les troubles que vous voyez actuellement
sur le macadam de paris seront cette
fois installé sur 2 débarque chez hante
elles remonteront le fleuve du pont de
grenelle au pont de sully
le tout bien sûr illuminé par un
gigantesque feu d'artifice
comment ceux d'entre vous qui n'auraient
pas la chance d'assister à ce carnaval
d'écart à mal et qu'il sera sur tf1
comme on découvre à l'événement un film
que pour eux pouvaient voir succèdent en
plein dans quelques semaines
voilà jean claude bourret je vous laisse
le soin de terminer ce journal sur ces
images du carnaval des carnavals de
barry bonds il se lie varie place de
l'hôtel de ville
cercle mais voilà des images qui
réchauffe un peu le coeur des français
le coeur des parisiens puisqu'il ne fait
pas très beau vous le savez sur
l'ensemble de la france
je vous répète que tf1 diffusera
prochainement un film d'une heure qui
sera un résumé de ce carnaval des
carnavals et tout à l'heure également de
15 à 17 grande cavalcade de la place de
l'hôtel de ville à la concorde ce soir
enfin à 22h sur la seine entre le pont
de grenelle et le pont de sully défilé
de chars navale et parmi eux celui
d'eddy fin de tf1 excellente après-midi
à tous et rendez vous ce soir à 20
heures
merci